Trascrizione: Isotta Rossoni
Revisore: Michele Gianella
Se vi dico che faccio la criminologa,
cosa vi viene in mente?
Probabilmente, alcuni di voi
mi immaginano già sulla scena del crimine,
guanti in lattice
con a fianco la scientifica.
Ed altri si stanno chiedendo
se prima della fine della giornata
li avrò schedati in un database.
Del tipo che qualcuno qui sta pensando:
"questa adesso scende,
e mi prende le impronte digitali".
La criminologia è un campo molto ampio,
ed effettivamente ci sono criminologi
che si avvicinano a queste descrizioni.
Io, però, passo la maggior parte
del mio tempo ad ascoltare storie.
Storie complesse, dolorose
con al centro le relazioni
e i rapporti sessuali;
e come protagonisti,
persone di tutte le nazionalità,
i generi, le professioni e le età.
A furia di ascoltare storie,
ho iniziato anche io a ripensare
ad alcuni episodi della mia vita
sotto una luce differente.
E così il mio essere criminologa
mi ha portata a rendermi conto
che anche in alcuni miei incontri sessuali
c'erano degli aspetti problematici.
Penso ad esempio alla mia prima volta.
Non ero così piccola, quand'è successo;
ma ci sono arrivata
completamente impreparata.
Ho iniziato a uscire
con un ragazzo che mi piaceva;
e dopo poco, lui ha iniziato a spingere
per avere dei rapporti sessuali.
Io lo baciavo, e lui mi infilava
le mani sotto al vestito.
Io lo invitavo a uscire a bere qualcosa,
e lui mi diceva "Vieni a casa mia,
che non ce la faccio più".
Ero all'estero da sola,
scappata da una realtà
che mi stava molto stretta.
Lo volevo?
Bah, forse si, forse no.
Non ne ero così sicura.
Volevo sentirmi abbracciata,
amata, accolta per chi ero.
Probabilmente avrei avuto bisogno
di parlarne con qualcuno:
ma non sapevo con chi,
e sicuramente non sapevo
come parlarne con lui.
Quindi, anche se non mi sentivo pronta,
anche se in fondo in fondo non lo volevo,
alla fine l'ho accontentato.
Anni più tardi,
mi trovo a una festa in maschera
organizzata dal ragazzo che frequento.
La festa finisce, gli amici se ne vanno,
e lui mi chiede di restare.
Io gli dico di sì.
Ho voglia di passare del tempo assieme,
ho voglia di baciarci, abbracciarci.
Ma non voglio fare sesso.
E glielo dico, eccome se glielo dico.
No dai, stasera non mi va.
Possiamo semplicemente abbracciarci?
Uff, non ho voglia!
La smetti?
Alla fine, cedo per sfinimento.
Forse alcuni di voi si staranno chiedendo:
ma perché non te ne sei andata?
Ma che ci facevi a casa sua,
se non volevi andarci a letto?
Reagiamo così in tantissime
situazioni come queste, e ben più gravi.
Ma se ci pensiamo bene,
se ci guardiamo dentro,
tanti di noi avrebbero
esperienze simili da raccontare.
Esperienze in cui il consenso
pieno e consapevole
è venuto a mancare;
e quindi c'è stata,
in qualche modo, della violenza.
Nonostante ciò,
raramente parliamo di sesso,
di consenso e di violenza
in maniera genuina e costruttiva.
A parlarne sono principalmente
i media, la televisione e i giornali.
E ne parlano facendo sensazione,
spesso banalizzando e stereotipando:
Party in spiaggia, due quindicenni
violentate dall'amico;
Corso Buenos Aires,
violenza sessuale in pieno giorno:
vittime due donne di 52 e 57 anni.
Audrey, stuprata dal marito.
"Ho denunciato, ma ho paura:
lui sa dove mi trovo".
Che emozioni vi suscitano queste storie?
Rabbia?
Indignazione?
Stupore?
Forse paura per voi o chi vi sta vicino?
Se i fatti succedono nelle nostre zone,
normalmente ci pensiamo
un po' più a lungo,
prima di tornare alla
"normalità" delle nostre vite.
Finora vi ho portato esempi
di violenza sulle donne
solo perché la violenza sulle donne
è veramente molto diffusa,
e questo ce lo dicono fior fior di studi
e ricerche internazionali.
Ciò non significa che siano
solo le donne a subire violenza.
Nel corso del mio lavoro,
e della mia ricerca,
ho incontrato donne e uomini
in relazioni eterosessuali e omosessuali,
ma anche persone transgender,
che hanno condiviso con me
le loro esperienze di violenza sessuale.
A parlare di violenza
sono anche gli esperti.
E lo fanno usando una marea di tecnicismi,
poco accessibili a chi si occupa di altro
e sicuramente, totalmente incomprensibili
alla me al suo primo rapporto sessuale.
E comunque, anche i tecnicismi,
che adesso ammetto di usare pure io,
possono servire per evitare
argomenti scomodi.
Ricordo, ad esempio
una conferenza internazionale
sulla violenza sessuale e di genere
in cui - non sono come, non so perché -
siamo finiti a parlare
di orgasmo femminile.
Io ero contentissima!
Ho iniziato subito a parlare
di un sito che utilizzavo
per esplorare il piacere femminile,
conoscere meglio il mio corpo,
la reciprocità nei rapporti -
Inutile dirvelo, li ho ammutoliti tutti:
ero andata troppo sul personale.
Eppure, il sesso è un atto
che milioni di esseri umani
compiono ogni giorno.
Be' dai, forse non proprio
tutti ogni giorno.
Il sesso genera gioia,
genera creatività, ispirazione;
ma può anche essere fonte
di dolore e di trauma.
Avviene in tantissime famiglie,
a volte in forme dannose
per una o entrambe le parti,
tra coppie giovani e coppie datate.
Insomma, è molto più vicino a noi
di quello che ci immaginiamo,
sia nel bene che nel male.
E allora perché ne parliamo così poco,
e in maniera così inadatta?
Perché nel 2022 il sesso è ancora un tabù,
è un qualcosa che da un lato
è spettacolarizzato nei film o sui social;
e dall'altro rimane qualcosa
di cui ci vergogniamo.
Siamo ben disposti a fare
quattro battute con gli amici;
ma se si tratta di metterci a nudo noi -
scusate il gioco di parole -
beh, quello è un altro discorso.
Infatti, la giovane e inesperta me
ne aveva parlato solo,
molto brevemente, con sua madre
dopo una visita dal ginecologo.
E la conversazione,
più o meno, era andata cosi:
"Devi usare i preservativi
perché se no ti vengono le malattie! "
"Siiiiii dai mamma, ok, va bene, va bene"
Vi confesso che non ho
neanche mai assistito
a una di quelle tipiche
lezioni da film americano
dove gli studenti vengono terrorizzati
sul rischio di prendersi clamidia,
gonorrea, epatite B, sifilide, HIV -
adesso anche vaiolo delle scimmie -
e poi fanno pratica mettendo
il preservativo sulla banana.
Banane e preservativi a parte,
non pensate che se iniziassimo
a parlare più liberamente di sesso,
ci sentiremmo tutti più accolti,
più accettati, meno soli?
Anzi, io sono convinta
che proprio perché non parliamo di sesso
quando potremmo e come dovremmo,
ci sentiamo inadeguati, a volte sbagliati,
perfino colpevoli di volere
o non volere qualcosa,
o di dire di no.
Così ci godiamo meno
le esperienze positive;
e allo stesso tempo,
crescono le incomprensioni,
i malintesi e gli abusi.
Proprio perché esperienze come la mia,
che alla fine sono forme
di "violenza quotidiana",
cioè veramente molto comuni,
non vengono viste come tali
né da chi le vive,
né dalla nostra società,
non emergono, oppure emergono tardi.
Se ci pensate bene,
non ha neanche tanto senso
vergognarsi del sesso.
Alla fine, è un atto come qualsiasi altro,
basato sulla comunicazione
verbale e non verbale.
Si tratta di comunicare
che sì, qualcosa ci piace;
che sì, qualcosa lo vogliamo;
quest'altra cosa un po' meno;
e questa proprio no.
Se, per esempio, a voi piace
che vi pizzichino i capezzoli,
ma non vi piace il sesso anale -
o viceversa, perché il mondo
è bello perché è vario -
questa è una cosa da comunicare.
Magari non ai giornali,
ma al vostro partner direi di si!
Il sesso, però, ha anche a fare
con ascoltare, e carpire,
il si, il no, il forse,
il magari dopo, non stasera,
il - proviamo qualcosa di diverso?
Comunicare i propri bisogni
non è sempre semplice,
anche perché, alcune volte,
non siamo sicuri neanche noi
di quali essi siano.
Mi permetto di dire che è
ancora più difficile per le donne,
che spesso fanno fatica a dire di no
ed hanno anche difficoltà
a esprimere fino in fondo il sì,
e non solo nell'ambito
dei rapporti sessuali.
Io, per esempio, soffro
della tipica sindrome dell'impostore,
per cui in contesti lavorativi
a volte di dico di si,
ma poi dubito di essere all'altezza;
e altre volte non sono
in grado di dire di no,
perché in fondo in fondo penso
che mi stiano facendo un favore.
Vi assicuro che ci sto lavorando:
ma grazie a conversazioni
con amiche e colleghe,
so che non sono sola.
Forse perché l'immagine
della donna docile,
eternamente accondiscendente
è veramente molto diffusa,
e l'abbiamo interiorizzata
tante di noi donne.
E forse, perché ci sono uomini -
e non solo uomini, certo -
che non sono in grado
di sentirsi dire di no.
E tra la difficoltà di verbalizzare,
ed esprimere i propri bisogni,
e l'incapacità di accogliere un rifiuto,
si annida la violenza.
Per prevenirla, contrastarla
e promuovere rapporti più sani,
c'è bisogno che iniziamo
a parlare di sesso
perché è un aspetto fondamentale
della vita di tantissimi esseri umani,
sia quando lo fanno
che quando non lo fanno.
Ciò di cui non si parla,
diventa sporco e vergognoso.
Rompere lo stigma che circonda il sesso
significa lasciar andare
tutti i pregiudizi e i preconcetti,
sia nei confronti degli altri
che verso noi stessi.
Certo, significa anche
sentirsi scomodi, molto scomodi.
Immaginate, ad esempio,
una cena con gli amici
in cui il vostro partner,
tutto d'un tratto,
tira fuori dei dettagli intimi
del vostro fare l'amore.
Ecco, scomodi così.
Ma anche vulnerabili.
Come mi sono sentita io,
quando ho iniziato
a frequentare un ragazzo
e gli ho dovuto spiegare
perché non volevo fare certe cose a letto.
Ma come si è sentito anche lui,
quando mi ha raccontato
che era stato mollato in tronco,
aveva sofferto molto,
e inconsciamente aveva paura
che tutte le donne
potessero fargli del male.
E questo aveva un impatto
sulla sua vita sessuale.
Conoscete la canzone
"Let's talk about sex", dei Salt-n-Pepa?
Il ritornello fa più o meno così:
"Let's talk about sex,
how it is, how it could be, how it was -
and of course, how it should be"
Parliamo di sesso, di com'è,
di come potrebbe essere, di com'era -
e ovviamente, di come dovrebbe essere.
Parliamone con i nostri partner fissi;
i partner occasionali; con gli amici;
se ce la sentiamo, in famiglia;
con i giovani.
C'è bisogno di creare degli spazi
dove donne, uomini,
persone non binarie, persone transgender
si sentano libere di poter condividere
il bello, ma anche il brutto del sesso.
Alcuni di questi spazi già esistono,
principalmente online,
e sono portati avanti da giovani,
che hanno iniziato la discussione
sul sesso, sul consenso e sul piacere.
Ma la strada è ancora lunga e tortuosa,
e conviene iniziare da noi.
E allora, incominciamo noi
a dire di sì, a dire di no, a dire:
"Questo mi piace!", "Questo un po' meno!";
a chiedere, ad ascoltare.
Parliamo di sesso senza paura
di sentirci scomodi e vulnerabili.
E viviamolo anche, mettendo da parte
tutte le aspettative,
gli stereotipi e i tabù.
(Applausi)